[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] you think you're dealing with I'm
gonna barbecue I got friends but before
that [ __ ] goes down we gotta get stung
to the [ __ ] gills I mean who wants to
see fireworks if you can't see the devil
way from behind I'm sad it's the fourth
of July [ __ ] happy fourth to your
families uncle Joey loves you with all
my [ __ ] heart we got some tremendous
weeds here we got a [ __ ] Disneyland
this [ __ ] is dead oh my god he got a
[ __ ] lemon oh gee from last night we
still got some of this [ __ ] gorilla
glue Oh [ __ ] Christ
that's like having to fight Frankie
Edgar Jose out though and [ __ ] Rafael
dos Anjos right there those three
[ __ ] containers but that's a window
right here this F we [ __ ] around just
so [ __ ] don't get confused you
know I'm saying
who needs the bidding just a little one
does the same [ __ ]
there's one of fourth-of-july spots
ready before I have burgers in the
[ __ ] hot dogs and the [ __ ] potato
salad the hair in the food there's
always a bag of reef for somewhere
people smoke on the garage your
grandmother's what's that [ __ ] smell
grandma don't worry about nothing was
spunk in here in this family you like
snot track talk something here it comes
will living it today's grandma but
what's with the chitter chatter Joey I
come back eight minutes then I gotta get
back to the [ __ ] barbecue so we had
to a [ __ ] speed we speed weed you
understand let's fill this [ __ ]
up
oh [ __ ] with some Disney get the party
started
you know me I'm already 22 Bozeman I got
up early this morning I went to [ __ ]
jujitsu I got beat the [ __ ] down
today they understand me my shoulder my
[ __ ] and help Bo my pinky I mean I'm
[ __ ] up that's why I'm always seeing
you guys in case I die my [ __ ] is sleep
tomorrow I go for [ __ ] pre-op they
get the blood to check the lungs they
check the nutsack then at this time next
week I'll be at home I'm like 22 [ __ ]
stars at death and me and 18 [ __ ]
knock those seeing the double you
understand me and pain suffering I can't
sleep Joey who gives a [ __ ] spark that
phone you're absolutely right
that's what these [ __ ] want to
see understand me I don't give a [ __ ]
about your operation then I'm [ __ ] about
that bugle on your face they don't give
a [ __ ] about nothing we're here to get
down to the ground you understand me a
time please [ __ ] Joey
spark that soldier let's hit this
[ __ ] lemon oh geez we'll do a pipe of
each of them just to let you know listen
you gotta get up early in the morning
uncle Joey in this family so this one up
to the [ __ ] brim
[Music]
and we're gonna get there working all
right Jenny chat about your [ __ ] nose
a new [ __ ]
when it makes a sunny day you could hear
that [ __ ] bird this [ __ ]
bird you and asked when I had it he
won't shut the [ __ ] up twig twig twig if
I had a slingshot
I'd knock him off his [ __ ] perch but
I'm a humanitarian
oh yeah
even the [ __ ] Indians are making a
comeback with this weekend they're
coming up from the grave right now
sometimes you gotta get stones I'm given
from what they tell you sometimes you
know everybody with their ATP tablets
and all this [ __ ] listen I want to do
speed by couple of [ __ ] black Batman
who [ __ ] me in the ass all the other
standing don't need no speed how much B
solo
nice
the breathing doctor beliefs assumption
[Music]
see this the old way that's [ __ ]
that means you're vertical you gotta
breathe through your [ __ ] yeah it's
like yeah it's like the follow [ __ ]
comes on the air so when you bring them
to come over here smoke of lemon drop
free friendship with people with had
some glasses
hanging out over a [ __ ] on the
boulevard day we love the coffee aroma
but now we got now we got [ __ ] at the
right top bar the weed opens up next
thing I got weed every [ __ ] landfill
floor is [ __ ] next you know I gotta get
back in the Subaru and take a right tool
bar get another three [ __ ] days but
we'll look cool before sign again that's
the [ __ ] hand I got it down low [ __ ]
powder you understand me nice and dry
nobody gets their feelings hurt
we're gonna just mooches damages if you
don't know now you know all right
if you don't know somebody's only want
then [ __ ] tell you
this is it what else you want dwarf
something mystical firecracker up my ass
we need to magic what the [ __ ] you
people want out here hanging out with
you before you go in that put up with
that [ __ ] here beaten from your hands
and my shake you get one bingo there's a
Sun with my eight walls
where's my [ __ ] a bowl of the concert
this a plane interrupted mean I think
I'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] plane bother me
back
that's it really listen what we do we do
all right what happens in [ __ ] Vegas
stays in Vegas what happens I will join
sports it stays on the porch all right
down suckers I love you guys thank you
happy fourth of July to you and your
families I hope you have bones of
delicious use the good [ __ ] all turkey
dogs all right don't [ __ ] drive me
crazy no turkey burgers all American
beef with chicken [ __ ] in it and that's
how you move forward around I love you
[ __ ] happy fourth the podcast is
wait for your [ __ ] ass and you
want iTunes or YouTube both there's Kate
you know I love you suckers Wednesday
Oh yet along with that they get oh happy
fourth of July before the key three key
happy flick III give aya I love you
[ __ ] have a great night with your
families watch your fingers